[Musik]
aktuell befinden wir uns hier in
mainland elend ist ein fiktiver start
der 1700 kilometer östlich von
österreich ist und der gestern in den
abendstunden von einem verheerenden
erdbeben heimgesucht wurde
diese klassifizierung übung die das
österreichische katastrophenhilfe
kontingent aposteln forces disaster
relief unit hier absolviert wird gemäß
den internationalen standards die von
der un ausgegeben wurden absolviert das
österreichische kontingent umfasst 83
soldaten das in ein kommando und
führungs element gegliedert ist das
schwergewicht bilden drei räte und berge
gruppen die in kürze mit ihrem einsatz
beginnen werden und rette und
bergemaßnahmen in diesem land
durchführen werden um eine
funktionsfähige druck gehilfe ich würde
mir jetzt richtung parkplatz bewegen und
dort dann auf meine befehlsausgabe von
meiner guten kompletten warten und
durch dann richtung einsatzraum
beziehungsweise schadstelle waren bereit
nicht nur seelisch geistig drauf und
inaktiviert menschenleben
[Musik]
für die vielleicht in sicht erst
maßnahme und dann haben wir uns
zusätzliche relativ einfach
vielleicht unterbrochen
der dinge ist jetzt das mal
auf links um haus und verletzten
die rettungsmaßnahmen
vornehmen
und
der aus nicht hinzuzufügen
wir mal aufbereiten
die beleuchtung getötet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so genossen
[Musik]
meine funktion zur zeit ich bin hier
eingesetzt als retter und berge
trockenkammer land die lage vor ort
schaut wie folgt das zurzeit ist eine
rettung im gange am dach oben wo der
räte druckt diese person mittels mannes
satz gegen absturz retten jetzt schauen
wir mal wer braucht heute versuchen
zeitgleich erfolgt links von mir aus
gesehen eine rettung durch den wer
gedopt dann zusätzlich haben wir vor
zwei minuten durch den rettungs und eine
anzeige im mittleren bereich der
schadenstelle gärten das heißt wenn die
zweite person gerettet ist werden wir
einen weiteren ansatz dann bei der
dritten person im durchführen
[Musik]
mein name ist nicht fertig ich bin hier
als rettungshundeführer mit eingesetzt
ich bin jetzt mit einem retter und berge
druck 24 ins kulturwerk mainland
gekommen
zu einer schadensstelle wir haben
derzeit die wunde zweimal in den im
einsatz gehabt im moment gerade die
person geborgen die durch unsere hunde
angezeigt wurde
[Musik]
da gehen
frage
und dann
st
euro
so schaut die lage so was dass wir vier
lebend rettungen durchgeführt haben
zur fünften vermissten person haben wir
sprechkontakt und schaffen zurzeit einen
zugang so dass man die fünfte person
ebenfalls reden können und somit ist für
uns immer die schadenstelle soweit
abgeschlossen
[Musik]